Listening to radiolab
radio from W. N y.
S. C. E. N. N. P. R. Maybe all of
us can sit on the couch. You can do,
I can rock and pull that chair over.
So we're going to start with
the story from my producer,
Pat Walters about a couple,
oh my word. It's the lady.
I'm Janet. This is the guy, I don't
need you to introduce yourself.
That's usually the thing we do, but
we're not telling people who you are.
We're going to call him Kevin. Kevin,
yeah, yeah, yeah. That's, yeah,
that's my name. That's suspicious at all.
It's not as real name.
I'll make sense why we're not
using his real name in a second.
Okay. You know, so this one starts a
few summers ago. It was July, 2006.
Jan and Kevin were at home and uh,
some people you don't know show
up and maybe out start with you
when they show up at their
door. So we were, it was a,
we were getting ready to go down
the shore. It was a Friday. So we,
so we're in the kitchen and,
and they come to the back door.
I thought the, I thought
that they were fundraising.
I thought they might've been firemen
just by, you know, the, the blue shirt,
the blue shirt, and then realized
that, uh, that they were,
they were law enforcement
[inaudible]
two women and a, I think two men more
came up from around the, you know,
the side of the house and
they show us their badges.
Were they cops or they
were homeland security.
They took me outside and they kept me
and they asked me to stay in the kitchen
and they had a, a woman with me.
I didn't know what was going on.
Nobody said anything.
What are they saying to you on
the porch? Meanwhile, when they,
when they showed up, like out to the
door, you said, you know why we're here.
I said, yeah, I do. I was expecting you
[inaudible]
and I showed them where everything was.
This story about Kevin and his wife,
Janet inspired us to do the entire hour
because one of the most basic things
that we do as people is we
judge, we judge one another,
could judge what's right,
judge what's wrong.
But this story and the two that follow,
they will make you judge how you judge
or at least they had that effect on us.
We're calling our show, blame them.
Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich and
we'll go back to bat. Before we do,
you should know that this show contains
some graphic difficult descriptions in a
few spots. If you're not in the
mood or if you have kids around,
you might want to sit this one out.
Okay. So what happened in that
first scene and what happens next?
Only makes sense. If we
go back a little first
about 15 years, it's just an ordinary day.
Kevin's going home from work and um,
I was driving home going about 65 70 in
the fast lane when suddenly there was a
thump in my chest.
Then he just a heat boating. After that,
he said suddenly he had this thickness
in my tongue. In my throat than
about taste in his mouth. Then
my hearing faded out. Any thoughts?
It's back when I finally did come to, uh,
he sees his car smashed into the
side of an apartment building.
I do recall the officers telling,
you know, you've been in an accident,
you've been in an,
and he remembers one of them insisted
that he smelled alcohol and I was talking
through clenched teeth cause I had
bit my tongue and uh, and my cheeks.
I was saying over and over again, I had
a seizure, I had a seizure. [inaudible]
Kevin's got epilepsy. He's had
it since he was a teenager,
but two years before this all happened,
he'd had surgery to remove the part of
his brain that was causing the seizures
and it seemed to have worked.
He was doing great and essentially wasn't
having seizures anymore until suddenly
you,
he was last year license. I
lost my license for a year.
Things had kind of taken a nosedive.
Like here he is, he's 35 years old.
I'm living with my brother,
I'm divorced and I have to call my daddy
and ask him now to drive me to and from
work and you think I need to do
something. This is not sustainable. No,
no, don't, don't need that.
So I walked into the office as HR person
where he works for a list of all the
employees, give me a list of
everybody and where they're from.
So she pulled it up, I go down the list
and I get to Janet Woodruff, Bloomfield,
only one that's really close to me five
minutes away. So I walk to her cube,
knocked on the, on the wall and uh,
introduced myself like, Hey, my name
is Kevin. I also work here. I've,
I've got this thing though. It's
kind of awkward. I, I can't drive.
And I was wondering if you'd
give me a ride. And uh,
she said yes.
[inaudible]
I really passed by his street.
I mean, on the way it works.
So it was like right on history pretty
much. But I made it clear, you know,
I'll do it when I can. And as they
drove together, they started talking,
finding out a little bit
more about each other.
Notice pretty quickly we liked the same
music and that was unique because I sort
of liked music that was
probably more in his error.
Kevin was seven years older than Jan.
What kind of music are you listening to?
Jackson Brown, mostly. Lot of
Jackson Brown, James Taylor
[inaudible] um, funny rate.
It's a little, you know,
Elton John, they found themselves
singing along to the lyrics.
You cannot sing with somebody day in
and day out and not have something
happened.
We wound up as a spring came, you know,
it's getting nice out. So now it's like,
well let's not go home. Let's
go out for a beer after work.
We're becoming good friends.
We liked each other.
But for Kevin it was a little
more serious than that.
I'm thinking about her starting to wake
up at night and one day in as Jenna is
dropping
him off, Kevin turns to
her and he says, Hey,
I really appreciate what you've done
for me. Let me take you to dinner.
Just as friends, just as
friends. Jen said, sure.
So May 30th, 1992 Highland pavilion.
Nicest restaurant in town,
so your friends takes you
to a four star restaurant.
You're thinking right away he thinks this
is a date or going on a date. Come on.
So now on panic stricken, we have our
dinner, we leave. We had a wonderful time.
Sure.
He drops me off and I handed her
the poem. What did the poem say?
You still have it? Yeah, I do.
Okay. This is a little slower.
Each time we sing on the way home,
I pray that traffic backs up so we can
sing together just a little longer and
the harmony can go on forever and each
time we reach my door I feel robbed
because we're always in mid song
or mid thought. If only I could.
He gets out and goes inside
and probably thinks, ah, Sam.
They gave her that poem.
She's going to be so smitten
with me and you go home and what
want to throw up. I just
thought, Oh God, I, you know,
next day I just looked at him and
said, listen, we got to clarify.
This is clearly just going
to be a friendship. He was
seven years older than me.
He had these, uh, brain, uh, you
know, surgery. He has epilepsy,
he's divorced. He has
two children in here.
You're catching the compassion here
too. I'm trying and he's just like,
I'm not asking you to marry me. I'm
asking you to go out on a few days.
Exactly. If you go out with me like
four times in the next six months,
I'm ahead of the game.
He just handled it and I don't think it
was long at all. I can't even remember.
But it wasn't long at all
before we were like a couple
[inaudible]
hey Kevin, I'm dopey. Dopey
in love. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Doing romantic things for her all the
time. Flowers, poems and paintings.
Illustration of the Jackson Brown cover.
And within a year we were engaged,
but all the while Kevin
is having seizures. Yeah.
Since the car accident more and more,
there was a point where
we were obviously dating,
she helping him make his bed and um,
he said she pulled off the pillow case.
It's covered with bloodstains
and one, two, three, four, five,
six of you can count the
number of seizures that I
had in between my tongue and
bled.
I knew nothing about epilepsy.
I had never seen anybody
have a seizure in my past.
Those would have been big red flags
that I would have just walked away.
But I just went with it
and they both went with it for a few
years until finally Kevin and Jan decide
this is enough. I wanted to be done with
it. I just needed to be done with it.
So they schedule a brain surgery,
uh,
which sounds like a big
deal and obviously it is,
but they had every reason to think
that this wouldn't change him.
I honestly thought that he was
going to come out of it fine. Better
cause that's what happened the first time.
Kevin had actually gone through a brain
surgery much like this one once before
and he'd come out pretty much the same
guy. He was still himself. In fact,
he made sure of it. I had a, I was awake
for the surgery and that's crazy. Yeah,
it was. I had to be awake.
I had to do with music.
[inaudible]
Kevin is a musician and the doctors told
him, they said that if I lost anything,
I was going to lose my
appreciation for music,
that it would be like music would
be white noise. I said, you know,
no. For me music was no
is part of my personality.
It was how I coped with my darkest
moments in dealing with epilepsy and
seizures. At 18 years
old, I'd have a seizure,
I take my harmonica and I'd find a place
with decent reverb somewhere and be
right where I needed to be. I
didn't want to lose that part of me.
So as the doctors were doing the
brain surgery, they had his head open.
They asked him to sing. You
remember what you're saying? Um,
and do the innocence,
some James Taylor and while he's saying
they would tickle different parts of his
brain and if to ever touch the part
that made him stop singing, they'd say,
okay, that's a part we can not take
out. Wow. Yeah. And in the end,
I think they ended up taking out like
four and a half centimeters, like a gall,
you know, a little bit bigger than
a golf ball. Wow. But afterwards,
as he was recovering,
I had my keyboard in the room and I
tried playing right away, Duh, Duh,
Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh.
And it works. The part of him that he
really cared about was still there.
Exactly. Yeah, it does it man. I fell
in love with after the first surgery,
so I thought, well, you know, now that
you've got to do a second surgery,
he's already been there on this road,
we're fine. And after that second surgery,
he did seem fine. Janet didn't
have her brother sneak my,
my keyboard up to the
room again. He was very,
very adamant that he wanted the
keyboard and play it a little
[inaudible]
just noodled a couple of notes, played a
couple of things and it was like, okay,
I'm there, still me. I was ready to go.
So you go home and like
it seems to have worked.
Yeah. As far as seizures go, we thought,
okay, this is it. We're home free.
And uh, I was just happy to
have some normalcy. But then
in the winter, right by
beginning the middle of January,
Kevin noticed he wanted to eat my
physical appetite a lot more than usual.
Like insane.
This is a guy who didn't eat
breakfast. He had minimal lunch.
You need having sensible dinner,
maybe a snack. That was it.
But now I could eat the couch. It
just was odd. It was not him normally,
but you know, you're like, okay,
maybe it's just a side effect from
the medications. But then the piano
[inaudible] he played
the piano for hours. Same songs. They
used to sing in the car together.
He has stuck on a piece. He would
play for hours. How many hours?
Eight. Eight, nine. And then
there was sex, you know,
we were happy, healthy couple. Kevin's
nodding. Yeah. Yeah, it was fine.
But what was abnormal was it was, it was
anywhere. Clearly. It wasn't like, oh,
we're in the supermarket, let's have
sex here. I mean, it wasn't like that,
but I mean it was,
I could just walk in the kitchen from
being out of work and he'd be like, Oh,
let's go here. Which struck her as
weird. But then again, we were thinking,
you know, let's try to have a family.
So the timing made things
confusing and more than that,
it wasn't like any of this stuff was
out of character. Exactly. In fact,
it was all stuff that she
liked about him. Yeah.
Except now it was all turned up to 11.
All the things that were
wonderful became chores
and that's pretty much
where things are at.
When those federal agents
showed up in July of 2006,
I was just completely blindsided. I said,
you know why we're here. I said, yeah,
I do. I was expecting yet
Kevin took the agents upstairs.
I took them right into here
where my computer was and
they arrested him for what
was on that computer. I gave it up
to him right away and warning, uh,
this next passage contained some
graphic imagery. I mean, I, I hadn't,
I don't know if I had fully,
like I think I had just like let child
porn be this kind of vague thing that
meant as someone younger than 18,
but then I read some of the court
documents and they were like toddlers.
They were picked videos of two, three,
and four year olds. They're there.
These sites had the most despicable,
disgusting things you can, you
can imagine infants on throw,
um, you know, pre preteen and you
know, pre-adolescent you know, in a,
in adolescence. Yeah. So yeah, it,
and you bought these things and
put them on your computer. I, yeah.
Yeah. It, it, it bothers me.
Yeah. It bothers me. Like, uh,
like I said, initially it was, you
know, it was just your base, your basic,
you know, Hetero Heteros,
heterosexual playboy, like penthouse,
like sites.
And then windows would just start to
open up and pretty soon he says he was
going everywhere there was gay
sex. They were, I mean, there was,
there was bondage, there
was a dedication. Sex,
there was animal sex, xeno sex.
I went everywhere that a
button came up to push.
I, I still don't understand it. I still,
I still don't understand it. He said
it disturbed you and you feel terrible.
But I just like wonder like, how
do you, do you tell yourself like,
that wasn't me.
Like how do you explain it to yourself
too so that you can kind of, I dunno,
not feeling like you're as bad
as the person who goes there
without a brain injury is, you know, like,
oh Aye. Aye. Aye.
Say that again. Ask that question. I
guess I'm just wondering, I don't know.
Like knowing that that's a thing that
you did and it sounds like obviously you
know that that was bad. It was a wrong
thing. And so what terrible thing. Um,
but it was, it was you who did it or was
it not? I Dunno. You know what I mean?
Now it, it was, it was me who
did it, but it was me with,
hey,
complete lack of neurological control.
Yeah. I mean, I, I, I
know, I know who I am.
I did idiotic things that I
couldn't stop myself from doing.
I didn't want to do it. There would be
nights where it would be four or five,
six hours of going to
the same site and and,
and downloading one or two
files and then deleting them,
going back a minute later, downloading
the same files, deleting them.
I would download those files a dozen times
and delete them a dozen times cause I
didn't want to be there and
knew I shouldn't be there
and couldn't help myself
from going back. I'm not
an idiot. I mean I'm, I'm,
I'm a smart guy. I'm not an idiot,
but I know I had no control
and that's what he would argue
in court. Can we plead guilty?
But at the sentencing hearing he
asked the judge to be lenient,
arguing essentially that the person
who did all those things in some sense
wasn't him.
It was some other part of his brain that
he couldn't control that the hearing,
he called one witness,
Orrin Devinsky. I'm a neurologist and
epilepsy specialist at NYU Medical Center.
He's been treating Kevin for
decades, 2020 some odd years.
And he says as soon as he found out
what Kevin had been doing had a terrible
sense of of responsibility. This
is because of the brain surgery,
the surgery Oren recommended he have
any argued in court that this was not
Kevin's fault.
I remember looking at those agents right
in their face and saying to them and to
the judge, this could be anybody.
This could be those agents, judge,
this could be you, this could be me,
this could be anybody and we would
have no control over what we did it and
explained to the court
what the biology was
[inaudible] that the way
the brain is organized,
that there are parts of our brain
that are way deep down that control.
Blake base desires.
Hunger. Sex keeps US alive,
but it's teeming with
the nastiest thoughts.
We all have these crazy thoughts
in our head now and most of us,
those thoughts are kept in check because
there are other parts of our brain that
sit on top and act like a
lid. But in Kevin's case,
the brain surgeon who did that surgery
removed part of that filter and suddenly
the cork was off.
I mean it was just no lid
on. His sexual desires
is that scientist have
known about it, about
this condition for a long time. If
her son, monkeys in rhesus monkeys,
when the monkeys would lose roughly the
same part of the brain that Kevin lost,
they became very hypersexual males
that would only previously be sexually
involved with females.
Now we're 10 times more sexually active
with both males and females that it
feels to me, it feels
to me like there's a,
there would be a brighter
line before kids, you know,
I think there is a line for
quote unquote normal individuals,
but in a brain disorder case,
those lines get blurred and he told
the court that's what happened here.
It was black and white. Kevin was sick
and his behavior was out of his control.
Well, that's not what the
facts showed in this case.
This is Lee Barton who was the prosecutor.
We saw no evidence of impulsivity.
He says, if you're claiming
that he had no control,
that his brain made him do it,
then how come he had all this
child porn on his home computer?
I believe it was 52 videos and 125 images,
and yet on his work computer,
they were zero images,
zero videos of child pornography on
his work computer, and he worked a lot.
He held down a job. He
was working every day.
If he truly lacked impulse control,
I would think you would see child
pornography on both computers.
And so what he argued back was what
was the lid on at work and off at home?
Seems to me to be an easy out.
So the answer is that this is
common with neurologic disease.
They tend not to be 24 seven is
let's take something like Tourette's.
Some people, when they're
engaged in playing sports,
they tend not to have ticks,
whereas when they're sitting
around bored or stressed,
they do tend to have ticks.
So you could say, well,
Therese clearly isn't a
neurological disorder,
but note Tourette's is
a neurologic disorder.
We understand some of the brain
things that go on Tourette's.
The prosecution didn't buy it.
They just thought it was hogwash.
What was hogwash was
his level of certainty,
um,
depressed skis and asked the Kevin
be sent to prison for five years,
isn't paying for child porn.
He was supporting an industry
that does terrible things to kids.
Kevin hope t to avoid jail time
altogether and instead be placed on house
arrest. That was per Janet
right after the arrest.
I have to imagine that you were
in shock a little like, yeah,
she'd gone to see a lawyer and
[inaudible]
one of the questions he asked was, is
this marriage going to survive this?
And I said, I don't know.
And at that point, understanding, I
didn't even know the level of pictures.
Yeah.
But she says the moment she heard orange
state that this was a brain disorder
with the name got Kluver BC syndrome.
Once I was able to get that from me
[inaudible]
it clicked. Like you couldn't blame it.
We have these experts saying that it was
a disease and I kept thinking they'll
understand. Not to mention that after
Kevin was arrested and got an unveil or,
and gave him some medication and Janet
says it was like flipping a switch.
That's exactly what it was. It was
like I got him back. I was able,
I was able to sit and watch a
movie with her, you know, normal.
Janet actually says in a lot of ways,
those few months between the
arrest and the sentencing hearing,
they'd been the best months of their
marriage. He now is just so much easier,
calmer. Uh, you could just talk,
the hearing took about three
hours and when it was over,
the judge took a recess, went into
her chambers. When she came back,
she delivered her decision.
[inaudible]
she actually wouldn't
talk to me for the story,
but I have the transcript
from the, uh, hearing. And um,
if you remember the prosecutor of the
Bar, Tan was asking for five years,
63 months or in Kevin, Janet were hoping
for house arrest, meaning no jail time.
There's no way they're gonna put
him in jail. This is clear cut.
And here's what the judge does.
She says, I do agree with orange.
It is a neurological disorder,
no question do we can't be held
fully responsible for his behavior.
She was getting it on the other and she
said the prosecution did have a point
that he was very much in control of his
impulses, at least some of the time.
And so the question for the judge was,
how does the legal system assigned blame
when a person is sometimes themselves
and in control and sometimes
not? Well, this was a crime.
She said a crime which ultimately
leads to children being harmed.
And considering that you did have
moments where you were in control,
then in those moments you
had a responsibility. You
could've done something,
you could have asked for help,
you could have told the people
around you what you were doing.
So even if you couldn't have stopped
yourself, they could have stopped you.
She made it very clear that we have
to do something here. His sentence,
26 months at a federal prison
and 25 months of house arrest.
And I, I believe, I believe
that she, she was, she was fair
and I,
I believe she was compassionate in about
a week before Christmas in 2008 Janet
drove him to prison. How long was
he in jail for? About two years.
And she was, even though the judge
said, you know, he is responsible.
Does that change her headed
to, toward him at all? No,
they totally stuck together. She
visited him pretty much every weekend.
The whole time
I knew the route and I had my own
little routine down in between visit,
she'd send up notes and I'll never forget,
he could send me mail and they had a
store where he could get some cards,
super call murky and he
would like alter them.
And I remember the very first card I got,
it was this very, you know, beautiful.
Supposedly it's supposed to be
beautiful, but it was like, you know,
if you need anything, you know
anything at all, just let me know.
And then he writes, of
course, if it's pressing,
you might want to ask someone else
because Oh well you can wait 24 months.
And I remember getting that and just
laughing and then that became our thing.
Like, listen, this is
a horrible situation,
but we're going to make the best of it.
Tell me a little bit about
like where things are at now.
I think things are, are,
are almost normal. Yeah.
Uh, you know, I, I am
still on probation. Yeah.
But he's home. Um, he's
working. Life is going on.
We have our normal routines.
Kevin still takes those medicines that
keep that other part of him in check.
I mean, I have no libido
all, but I know who I am.
I know what I am. Um, um,
I'm disturbed by that portion of
my life, but, um, I'm, I'm trying,
I'm trying to move on.
[inaudible]
producer Pat Walters.
Thanks also to neurologist or Devinsky
for connecting us to Kevin and Janet.
Stay with us.
We'll be exploring these questions if
blame and responsibility even more deeply.
The next site.
Don't even yell about it
a little. Yeah. Coming up.